[Music]
in order to step into the most powerful
version of yourself you need to have
clarity of intention you need to know
not just what you want but why you want
it put your honor
where your mouth is when you give your
word keep it
show up
do the work
get your hands dirty i love being number
one i love winning but it's the times
when things go wrong when you fall or
fail that you're actually gone going to
learn
the most about yourself
i learned back in the 80s after reading
gary zukov's book seed of the soul so in
that book he speaks of cause and effect
that's the third law of motion in
physics which says that for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
also known as karma or what goes around
comes around and before there is a cause
or action there is always an intention
that fuels that action a motivation or
reason behind the action
the reaction will reflect what that
intention is for example i used to have
the disease to please i lived that way
until my late 40s saying yes to things
when i really wanted to say no can
anybody relate to that
why would i say yes because i didn't
want to upset anybody and i never did
because when your main intention is
pleasing other people they do that get
pleased then keep asking you for more
until you're the one who's upset so this
principle is at work in big and small
ways all the time
someone apologizes to you but they're
not really sorry what you hear is their
words but you feel the energy of their
intention
we see this often in relationships where
the intention is to have a big splashy
ceremony and all the energy goes into
making a fantastical wedding with no
clarity of intention for what the
day-to-day marriage will look like
well learning this principle of
intention was a life-altering
life-enhancing transformational
experience for me it changed everything
the way i moved through the world the
way i did business who i chose to work
with everything it is i believe the one
reason that the oprah winfrey show was
number one for 25 years because we were
an intentional show with not just a
mission but a daily practice a mission
to use television to uplift enlighten
and entertain and that was because after
learning this principle i brought my
whole team together and said from this
day forward we do not do a show unless
we are aligned in our intention so when
you all bring me an idea state your
intention at the top and my yes will
come only if i can feel that i can
accomplish or align with whatever you're
doing
so you want an interview tell me what
the intention is what do you want i ask
every guest that i'm interviewing with
from whitney houston to my sit downs
with lance armstrong shaka sankor the
mother who lost her daughter to domestic
violence and most recently even harry
and megan before the interview i say
tell me your intention so you get the
idea intention is ruling your life
whether or not you're aware it is law it
is one with cause and effect and you
can't have action or reaction without it
so in order to step into the most
powerful version of yourself you need to
have clarity of intention you need to
know not just what you want but why you
want it so let's start by setting your
intention for this week and after today
we're going to meet every week going
forward to create a more intentional
life to discuss what needs to happen and
what will be your why your motivation
for making it so it all starts with
thinking about why you do the things you
do and if you're not getting the results
you want don't look at the results look
at what fueled it the intention
need motivation watch the top team
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
oprah winfrey and my take on our top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two embrace failure let
failure be your friend
there are going to be times
of course
where you're going to win a lot
a lot of things are going to go your way
and it's wonderful
to bask in that adulation and to feel
proud of your successes
but they're also going to be times the
satisfaction that those moments bring
nothing can compare to that those
victories will feed you for years to
come and help you stake a minute
when your tank is sometimes empty
winning is great it's fantastic i love
it i love being number one i love
winning
but it's the times when things go wrong
when you fall or fail
that you're actually gone going to learn
the most about yourself
you know
all those years on the oprah show
25 years we were the number one show for
25 years and that's because i lived with
the intention
to serve the audience the audience came
first every show i would sit with the
producers and say well i can't do that
because i can't find the truth of myself
in that show i have to have a thread of
truth to be able to hold on to so i knew
so well the audience i felt like i was
the audience the audience
was me
and i felt so connected
and then i ended that and started a new
network
and i flailed for a while
and i was really upset with myself
but i will tell you
that when i was able to shift the
paradigm to start to looking at wow what
i have instead of what i don't have what
i have instead of what i thought i'd
lost i was able to begin to turn things
around but it's those moments of being
of uncertainty it's the moments where
you know all of my mistakes show up on
the evening news you can make a mistake
i can tell if i've done something wrong
it's on the cnn crawl i can read about
it
but learning from the moments where
things weren't going so great being able
to get still
to connect with that which i know is god
the force the power greater than myself
and to come back
and realize that in order to move
forward you move forward by taking the
next right step you don't have to know
everything to do you don't have to know
all the steps to make just what is the
next right move rule number three care
enough to try it's true you can't
personally stop anybody from walking
into a school with an assault rifle nor
can you single-handedly ensure that the
rights that your mothers and your
grandmothers fought so hard for will be
preserved for the daughters that you may
someday have
and it'll take more than you alone to
pull 40 million americans out of poverty
but who will you be if you don't care
enough to try and what mountains could
we move i think what gridlock could we
eradicate if we were to join forces and
work together in service of something
greater than ourselves
you know my deepest satisfaction and my
biggest rewards have come from exactly
that
pick a problem
any problem
and do something about it because to
somebody
who's hurting
something
is everything rule number four create
meaningful connections i wanted to share
with you
this line from brene brown's latest
extraordinary new book atlas of the
heart that will be available come this
tuesday
november 30th she says
our connection with others can only be
as deep as our connection
with ourselves
that's what we're talking about this
week
and there perhaps is no time in recent
memory when it's more necessary to
actually cultivate empathy and
connection in order to make sense of the
profound
changes that we're all undergoing we
just everywhere we turn
we can't grapple with the many urgent
issues facing us
and facing our planet without
understanding
ourselves first and in atlas of the
heart brene and her team of researchers
and therapists and educators and others
have so richly explored how to cultivate
an emotional vocabulary like we need the
words the language the expressions that
help us process
and identify what it is we're feeling
and what is happening to us and to be
able to communicate that to other people
and what they've discovered is that
without that we won't find the solid
ground within us that gives us the
courage and the confidence to embrace
love to embrace happiness and our own
vulnerability to face and transcend our
pains or to navigate the great
uncertainty
that is the human condition so in
grenade's word she says with an
adventurous heart and the right maps we
can travel anywhere and never fear
losing ourselves even when we don't know
where we are i just love that the solid
ground the anchor we're searching for is
connection
and it is within each of us but to forge
meaningful connections with others
again we have to first connect with
ourselves and i know we're doing a lot
of connecting this week with family and
friends
we have to establish a common
understanding of the language of
emotions and human experience in order
to do that
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five get still as
you're trying to figure out what do i do
how should i do it first of all i will
say this
that when you don't know what to do my
girls have heard this over a hundred
times when you don't know what to do you
do nothing
you get still until you do know because
when you have to ask everybody else
should i should i should i do this [ __ ]
i should have and that's whether it's
buying a pair of shoes
or going with a guy buying a house
taking a job should i should i should i
when you have to ask everybody else it
means you don't really know the answer
fully yourself so you get still be still
and know
the answer will come rule number six
stand for something here are variations
on a few grand themes beginning with
this pick a problem
any problem the list is long here are
just a few
that are at the top of my list there's
gun violence and there's climate change
and systemic racism
economic inequality media bias
the homeless need opportunity the
addicted need treatment the dreamers
need protection the prison system needs
reforming the lgbt community
the
lgbtq community needs acceptance
the social safety net needs saving and
the misogyny needs to stop
[Applause]
needs to stop
but you can't fix everything
and you can't save every soul but what
can you do
here and now
i believe you have to declare war on one
of our most dangerous enemies and that
is cynicism because when that little
creature sinks in its hooks into you
it'll cloud your clarity it'll
compromise your integrity it'll lower
your standards it'll choke your empathy
and sooner or later
cynicism shatters your faith
when you hear yourself saying oh it
doesn't matter what one person says oh
well so what it's not going to make any
difference what i do who cares when you
hear yourself saying that know that
you're on a collision course for our
culture and i understand how it's so
easy to become
disillusioned so tempting to allow
apathy to set in because anxiety is
being broadcast on 157 channels 24 hours
a day all night long
and everybody i know is feeling it
but these times
these times are here to let us know
that we need to take a stand
for our right to have hope
and we need to take a stand with every
ounce of wit and courage we can muster
the question is what are you willing to
stand for
that question
is going to follow you throughout your
life
and here's how you answer it
you put your honor
where your mouth is
put your honor
where your mouth is
when you give your word keep it
show up
do the work
get your hands dirty and then you'll
begin to draw strength from the
understanding the true knowing that
history is still being written
you're writing it every day
the will's still in spin and what you do
or what you don't do will be a part of
it rule number seven have constructive
engagement more than ever i would have
to say i miss the oprah winfrey show i
chose to let it go i felt that i said
everything i needed to say after 25
years and i wanted it to be my decision
when i let it go but i will say this
past year
and now more than ever i miss it because
i miss the opportunity for the spirit of
constructive engagement that that
platform offered
so two weeks after
the election last year
uh i went to a diner in queens for oprah
magazine with a group of women
half of them were trump supporters half
of them were hillary supporters nobody
wanted to come to breakfast i was like
it's gonna be some great great great
croissants we're gonna have some nice
jams ladies
nobody wanted to sit down and have the
croissants
uh so everybody came in the room all
tight and hardened and so we were able
to i was able to they were like well
i've never been this close to these uh
hillary elitists i've never been this
close and their other people were saying
well i never said this close to trump
supporter before but we're going to do
it i will tell you after two and a half
hours i had those women not only eating
croissants
sitting around the table
listening to each other's stories
hearing both sides
and by the end they were holding hands
exchanging emails and phone numbers and
singing reach out and touch we're all
pretending to be diana ross which means
it's possible it can happen so i want
you to work
in your own way to change the world in
respectful conversations with others
at a rate and a rhythm that's in tune
with the source from which you have
come
your truth
and i want you to enter every situation
aware of its context
open to hear the truths of others and
most important open to letting the
process of changing the world change you
that is the spirit of constructive
engagement so that's the goal
to
be a compassionate woman of substance to
be committed to have constructive
engagement to live this life of
substance
substance
what i know for sure is if you focus on
the substance the success will come rule
number eight choose
you these past few weeks i've been
thinking a lot about adele and our one
night only conversation that we had for
cbs such a beautiful conversation in
concert
and beautiful album you can feel her
heart and soul in every lyric on 30.
her emotional pain she seems to have
used as a muse i said that to her during
our conversation and you know by now
that she wrote that album while going
through a divorce
and she told me that she left her
marriage in pursuit of her own happiness
and she has so many meaningful things to
say about choosing you
and not being guilty about it the
pursuit of your own happiness
is enough of a reason to make a major
change like adele did
let that sink in for a minute
so how did adele find the bravery to
trust herself and uproot her life i
asked her just that and her answer
struck me she told me that she imagined
the person
she would want her nine-year-old son to
know
when she was unhappy which she was in
the marriage
he her son wasn't getting the best
version of her
so adele dedicated the album to him as a
way of telling him
what she was going through
so of course
adele situation is specific to her but
the greater lesson can apply to just
everyone
so many women stay in miserable
situations whether it's their job their
friendships romantic relationships and
even encounters with family members
because
they don't feel
they have the strength or the right
to let go
they might feel scared to put themselves
first to listen to that voice that's in
your
spirit saying do what's best for you
make the change
the best thing i gathered from this new
30 album along with being soothed by
the music it's such a great album is an
even more compelling understanding that
choosing happiness for yourself
is what truly allows you to begin
bringing happiness to other people so
during the holiday season we all are
being we've already been conditioned to
give and give and given given given give
to others but it's important to make
time for yourself too
that care is the gift you give to
yourself
and
that's what we're taking
away from this week i'm hoping
being able to choose what's right for
you
and knowing when it is right rule number
nine
serve i was not your age
but about
30 years old i started to realize
that it was my whole life
not just parts of my life just not parts
of what i was doing but my whole life
was a prayer
my whole life is an offering
in service
first
to yourself
to become a fully actualized human being
and you do that through your actions and
your interactions
with others but when i started to
realize it's not just what i do but it's
how i do it it's how i'm not just
praying on my knees but i live in a
state of humility on my knees in service
to the higher calling of my life that
things started to change and rule number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus clips
is inspire and motivate eat a good
breakfast
it really pays off
pay your bills on time
recycle make your bed
aim high
say thank you to people and actually
really mean it ask for help when you
need it and put your phone away at the
dinner table
[Applause]
just sit on it
really and know that what you tweet and
post in instagram today might be asked
about in a job interview tomorrow
or 20 years from tomorrow
be nicer little kids be nice to your
elders
be nice to animals and know that it's
better to be
interested
than interesting
invest in a quality mattress
i'm telling you
your back will thank you later and don't
cheap out on your shoes
and
and
if you're fighting with someone you
really love for god's sakes find your
way back to them because life is short
even on our longest days
and another thing
another thing you already know that
definitely bears repeating don't ever
confuse what is legal with what is moral
because they are entirely different
animals
you see in a court of law there are
loopholes and technicalities and
bargains to be struck but in life you're
either principled or you're not
so do the right thing especially when
nobody's looking and while i'm at it do
not equate money and fame with
accomplishment and character because i
can assure you based on the thousands of
people i've interviewed one does not
automatically follow the other something
else something else you need to know
this your job is not always going to
fulfill you
there will be some days that you just
might be bored
other days you may not feel like going
to work at all
go anyway
and remember that your job is not who
you are it's just what you're doing on
the way
to who you will become
every every every every remedial chore
every boss who takes credit for your
ideas that is going to happen
look for the lessons because the lessons
are always there
i was inspired by yet another book will
smith who has just released his memoir
and i'm telling you it's a remarkable
achievement it's it's so honest and
packed with so many wonderful life
lessons and aha moments and yet it
sounds just like will's voice because he
wrote it
and one of those
lessons that really stuck with me is a
story he tells from his childhood
growing up in west philadelphia about
building a brick wall yes an actual
brick wall he was 11 years old and his
father needed a new wall constructed in
front of his shop a 12 foot high 20 foot
long wall to replace an old one that was
crumbling and his father who the family
called daddio assigned the job to will
and his brother harry and first daddyo
demolished the old wall leaving this big
gaping hole
and then it was up to will and his
brother harry to build a new one brick
by brick now will describes that task he
says it seemed overwhelming and endless
and their father didn't care if it was
raining or cold
if his sons didn't feel like working
that day week after week they worked to
rebuild that wall yet they didn't feel
they were ever making any progress and
so the two little boys now are working
on holidays during their vacations on
the weekends
over the course of a year they mix
concrete and toted that what seemed to
seem like millions of bricks back and
forth and if they were in bad moods or
sick or had
tests to take the next day daddy-o
didn't care that wall had to be built
and on a day that they were in a
particularly stark mood as will
describes it they protested to their
father that the job was impossible that
it was ridiculous that these two little
boys are being asked to build this wall
and that it would never get done so
here's where the aha moment came tired
of hearing his sons complain will's
father daddy oh threw down his tools
walked over to the wall to be and said
stop thinking about the damn wall there
is no wall there are only bricks and
your job is delayed this brick perfectly
then move on to the next brick then lay
that brick perfectly then the next one
don't be worrying about no wall your
only concern is
one brick
and will says that sunk in and he writes
that when i focused on the wall the job
felt impossible never ending but when i
focused on the brick just one brick
everything got easier
as the weeks pass the bricks mounted and
the hole got just a little bit smaller i
started to see that the difference
between a task that feels impossible and
a task that feels doable
is merely a matter of perspective are
you paying attention to the wall or are
you paying attention to the brick
so when life feels overwhelming when a
task at hand is daunting when you look
ahead and you think oh no it's just too
much can't do that
you can take daddio's advice and think
about things brick by brick i just love
this analogy one brick at a time
one baby step at a time if necessary so
that's a half a brick if need be
will writes that every single day no
matter where you are going or what
you're going through there's always
another brick sitting right there in
front of you waiting to be laid the only
question
are you going to get up and lay it so
this week everybody just take things
brick
by brick and before you know it what
felt like a wall that was impossible to
build
that grief you thought you'd be
impossible to endure that achievement
you thought was out of your grasp you'll
suddenly find
and yep
you have built a wall
you made it through
one
brick at a time it doesn't matter how
far you might rise at some point
you are bound to stumble because if
you're constantly doing what we do
raising the bar
if you're constantly pushing yourself
higher higher
the law of averages not to mention the
myth the vigorous uh predicts that you
will at some point
fall
and when you do i want you to know this
remember this
there is no such thing as failure
failure is just life trying to move us
in another direction now when you're
down there in a hole it looks like
failure
so this past year i had to spoon feed
those words to myself
and when you're down in the hole when
that moment comes it's really okay to
feel bad for a little while
give yourself time to mourn what you
think you may have lost
but then
here's the key learn from every mistake
because every
experience encounter and particularly
your mistakes are there to cheat you and
force you into being more of who you are
the greatest lesson i've learned
throughout my career came from maya
angelou actually
when i was you know first meeting her
and
after i'd known her for a while she said
baby you know
you need to know that when people show
you who they are
you believe them
the first time
oh you know that lesson too now
first time and uh your problem is it
takes you 29 times to see the same
lesson coming in a different skirt
wearing a different pair of pants so i
think that has been one of my
greatest wisdom teachings is to
assess
uh from people's behavior their actions
not just towards me but towards other
people
uh who they are and how they behave
because if people talk about other
people they'll talk about you so i think
in business and in personal
relationships that's also been my
greatest lesson the challenge of life
i have found is to build a resume
that doesn't simply tell a story
about what you want to be
but it's a story about who you want to
be it's a resume that doesn't just tell
a story about what you want to
accomplish but why
a story that's not just a collection of
titles and and positions but a story
that's really
about
your purpose because when you inevitably
stumble
and find yourself stuck in a hole
that is the story that will get you out
what is your true calling
what is your dharma what is your purpose
the way to make movies is to do stuff
that you love because you know for 25
years i worked on the oprah show
and
uh stephen will tell you that there were
date nights that i came home and i
almost you know it's hard to even like
take off my clothes because i knew i was
going to be getting up four hours later
but i never really felt exhausted
like depl never i felt exhausted but i
never felt depleted so do the work that
comes straight from
the soul of you from your background
from stories that you've grown up with
from stories that bring you passion from
stories that you uh not just yearn to
tell
but that if you don't tell them they
won't get told and when you when you are
operating you know the single the single
greatest uh
wisdom i think i've ever received other
than when people show you they are is
that
the key to fulfillment success
happiness
contentment in life
is when you align
your personality
with what your soul actually came to do
i believe everybody has a soul and has
you know their own personal
spiritual energy so when you can use
your personality to serve whatever that
thing is
you can't help but be successful so if
you do films that come from the interior
of your soul you do work you do art that
comes from the interior of you
it you cannot miss
it's only when you're doing stuff that
you think might make money you think it
may be a
hit or you think it may
uh bring you some level of attention or
success that isn't what does it i would
have to say that all of the great
wonderful experiences of my life that
have brought me to this moment have come
from working from the interior of myself
and so that's why it feels so authentic
because it
it actually is
so when you do that you'll win there
comes a point
and i'm really i'm really good at this
is at not holding on to what was
and being able to live in this present
moment you know i never was one of those
women who's afraid to tell your age or
you're trying to be something you're not
i mean i think
for everything there's a time and a
season
uh the bible is
completely right about that i think i
think um
and you know in your own self when it's
time to move from that my television
career began unexpectedly
as you heard this morning i was in the
miss fire prevention contest
that was when i was 16 years old in
nashville tennessee
and you had the requirement of having to
have red hair in order to win
up until the year that i entered so they
were doing the question and answer
period because i knew i wasn't going to
win in the swimsuit competition so
during the question and answer period
the question came why young lady what
would you like to be when you grow up
and by the time they got to me all the
good answers were gone
so
i had seen barbara walters on the today
show that morning so i answered i would
like to be a journalist
i would like to tell other people's
stories in a way that makes a difference
in their lives and the world
and as those words were coming out of my
mouth i went whoa this is pretty good
i would like to be a journalist i want
to make a difference well i was on
television by the time i was 19 years
old and in 1986 i launched my own
television show
with a relentless determination to
succeed at first i was nervous about the
competition and then i became my own
competition raising the bar every year
pushing pushing pushing myself as hard
as i knew sound familiar to anybody here
eventually we did make it to the top
and we stayed there for 25
years
the oprah winfrey show was number one in
our time slot for 21 years and i have to
tell you i became pretty comfortable
with that level of success every single
day to channel our own inner jucindas
to exemplify the truth
and the respect
and the grace
that we actually wish for the world
we need to tell it as we're doing at
this conference we need to write it
we need to sing it we need to proclaim
it
we need to be it we need to be the truth
we have to be the respect we have to be
the fierceness the love that we want to
see
and when we do that mark my words a
change is already
coming i wake up in the morning what you
do and the first thing i say is thank
you
that's my first thing
even before i'm awake you know before my
eyes are really fully open i i say thank
you i can feel the gratitude like i'm
still here i'm in a body thank you so
much i thank you for that and then i go
through the letting the dogs out the
whole you know brushing your teeth and
all that stuff and then i have either
silence or prayer or something that
acknowledges that i'm still here i do
not reach for that phone first that's
your problem you have no idea of the
power
of
noticing
another human being
and what it feels like when somebody
knows that they have been seen truly
seen by you
it is the greatest offering you can give
and all those years of the oprah show
the greatest lesson i learned was that
you know after every show
uh someone would say invariably in one
way or another um
how was that i finished an interview
with father who killed his twin
daughters i'd finish an interview with
politician barack obama joe biden george
bush they beyonce they all say the same
thing
how is that
and so i started to see that there's
this common thread in our humanity
where everybody wants to know
how was that
did i do okay
did you hear me
and did what i say
mean something to you
so i would have to say that
recognizing that in other people has
helped me to become you know a person of
compassion a person of understanding
person who can interview anybody about
anything because i know that if the core
of you is the same as core me you just
want to be heard have you ever made a
complete fool of yourself over a
celebrity
[Applause]
[Music]
i have i've never shared this story with
you but today i feel i have to
let it out it was 1973 or four i was uh
19 or 20. i can't quite remember but i
was working in nashville and i had this
obsession i mean
obsession with neil diamond
[Applause]
now
i would wake up
i would wake up in the morning playing
song song blue everybody and i would go
to bed to grackle and rosie and which is
not an easy thing to do in high school
because i could have lost my negro
membership card
you know there were not a lot of negroes
singing
crackling rosie but okay so i'm working
in television at this television station
and there was some kind of benefit and
neil diamond was there because he was
performing in town and so i'm in the
green room and i am by the time 1973 i'm
already uh anchorwoman on tv and so i
walk into the green room and there he is
and so i say mr diamond would you like
some shrimp
[Applause]
and he said and he says yes yes i'll
take a show and he took her shrimp and
i'm like
okay
and then he moved across the room and
then i followed him across the room
that's a big mistake that's the big
mistake people make so i follow him
across the room and so i'm like would
you like a another shrimp
and he said
yeah i'll take i'll take a shrimp
he did and then i followed him again
so i'm just staring at him across the
room
and finally i walked up and he goes
enough already
enough already okay so that was my
new
diamond moment i know you all understand
better than most that real progress
requires
authentic
an authentic way of being
honesty and above all empathy
i have to say that the single most
important lesson i learned in 25 years
talking every single day to people
was that there is a common denominator
in our human experience
most of us
i tell you we don't want to be divided
what we want the common denominator that
i found in every single interview is we
want to be
validated we want to be understood
i've done over
35 000 interviews in my career
and
as soon as that camera shuts off
everyone always turns to me and
inevitably in their own way asks this
question
was that okay
i heard it from president bush
i heard it from president obama
i've heard it from heroes and from
housewives i've heard it from victims
and perpetrators of crimes i even heard
it from beyonce and all of her beyonce
she finishes performing hands me the
microphone and says was that okay
friends and family yours enemies
strangers in every argument in every
encounter every exchange i will tell you
they all want to know one thing
was that okay
did you hear me
do you see me
did what i say mean anything to you
and even though this is the college
where facebook was born
my hope is that you will try to go out
and have more face-to-face conversations
with people you may disagree with
[Applause]
[Music]
that you'll have
the the courage
to look them in the eye and hear their
point of view
and
help make sure that the speed and
distance
and anonymity of our world doesn't cause
us to lose our ability to stand in
somebody else's shoes
and recognize all that we share as a
people this is imperative for you as an
individual and for our success as a
nation what about something that you
feel like you've personally achieved or
overcome is there something that you are
especially proud of yourself for yeah
i'm
especially proud of myself for not uh
living in the world of comparisons you
know uh years ago when i pulled out that
wagon of fat i was actually comparing
myself to everybody else or what i
thought you're supposed to look like or
what size you're supposed to be so i've
now reached the point where i'm really
okay
exactly where i am and that's you know
it's taken me a lifetime practically to
figure that out and being okay exactly
where you are because preparing is a
danger it's so hard because we are in
the world of insta comparison you know
and so
the real spiritual practice is to like
live from within and not let the world
divine who you are but you
do that for yourself that's that's the
hardest work you um are now the ceo of
your company you're the owner and the
ceo and you've got thousands of people
working for you yeah and as a ceo do you
have to say no to people all the time
and is that hard to do uh you get other
people who say that no okay um saying no
is hard that is one of the big big
lessons life lessons for me i i grew up
obviously girl
uh raised in the south woman need to
please wanting to please everybody so it
took me a long time to get that lesson
of only saying yes to what you intend to
say yes to and and so
uh i tried to do all of my business
decisions and personal decisions based
upon
my intention many of you
as i have been as i am are where you are
in your life
based upon what you believe and it's not
just what you think you believe on the
surface it's also your shadow beliefs
that are holding you back from moving
into the life that you believe
you deserve what i know is if you're not
looking at the shadows if you're not
looking at what is subconsciously
running through the tape in your mind
telling yourself you're not good enough
you're not worthy enough you're not
smart enough you're not enough
which is a tape that's playing for a lot
of people
if you're not conscious of that
then you end up acting out of that
belief system and not out of what you
know to be the truest or want to be the
truest for yourself but you don't become
what you want because so much of wanting
is about
living in the space of what you don't
have that's why jim carrey's story is so
powerful because he started to act as
though he already had it he would go up
to mulholland drive he would drive away
saying thinking i already have those
things i just haven't accessed them as
yet i believe those things are going to
come to me and i'm going to act like
they are so i'm going to move forward in
my life in order to
draw that to myself in such a way that
my actions are in alignment with what i
say i believe
so if you start to think about that
really why are you where you are in your
life the biggest transformation for me
was living my life with intention you
know what i know i live by this law of
that's the third law of motion physics
which you put out is coming back but
before you even put it out you have an
intention and so to have a clarity of
intention about what you actually want
to do and why you want to do it is the
most important thing and then to just
set that vision and have every step you
make move you in the direction of that
vision it doesn't mean that every day
it's gonna happen some days you're off
track like i intended to work out 45
minutes i only got in 37 this morning
well that's better than two it's better
than zero and that's that's that's
that's what i said okay at least you got
some movement in and i'll go back and
i'll make up the other eight later but
i think you just made it up
actually as i was walking i think i
think this is gonna be eight minutes i'm
gonna make it up so uh it's it's about
it's daily renewal it's not one big
gigantic goal it's every day coming back
giving yourself the opportunity to get
it right there has to be some way
that this darkness
can be banished with light
says the man whose little boy
was massacred on just an ordinary friday
in december
so whether you call it
soul or spirit or higher self
intelligence
there is i know this there's a light
inside each of you
all of us
that illuminates your very human
beingness if you let it and as a young
girl from rural mississippi i learned
long ago that being myself was much
easier than pretending to be barbara
walters
although when i first started because i
had barbara in my head i would try to
sit like barbara talk like bob or move
like barbara and then one night i was on
the news reading the news and i called
canada kanata
and uh
that was the end of me being barbara i
cracked myself up on tv
couldn't stop laughing and my real
personality came through and i figured
out oh gee i can be a much better oprah
than i could be a pretend barbara i have
a very big life
and so people with big lives can do big
things and so i started to think about
what was the best christmas i ever had
in my life i grew up poor
uh on welfare with my mother for part of
my life
and i remember that the best christmas
of my life was when i was 12 years old
and
my mother had said
we're not going to have christmas
because we can't afford it
and my feeling at the time was okay well
so that ruins that santa claus bit
it's 12 that's when i realized there was
no santa claus because now he ain't
coming because we're poor
and uh
i remember feeling like
it's going to be really hard on
christmas morning to go outside
everybody had you know you go outside
with your toys what am i going to do
when everybody else is outside
that's what i thought what am i going to
do when everybody else is outside and
what am i going to do when i have to go
back to class and say i got nothing so
that's what i was mostly worried about
and then some nuns showed up
some three nuns came to our house and
they gave me a doll and they bought us
food and we had our christmas that was
the best christmas of my life because
somebody remembered and i wasn't going
to have to be
the kid that said i got nothing so i
wanted to be able to create that same
feeling
for
children who had nothing
so i decided to go to south africa
originally i wanted to do a million kids
because i thought we can do a million
kids and then just realize with i only
had uh four weeks vacation so in four
weeks i could not reach a million kids
because i didn't want to just write a
check
send a donation i wanted to be able to
look in each kid's face and say to that
child somebody remembered you and so
that's what i did with my life this
christmas i took 41 people from here
hired another 50 people over there and
we were traveling caravan from one
village to the next we did 2 000 kids a
day we had
parties for children who were orphans
and it was singularly i will tell you i
could weep thinking about it the
singularly the best experience of my
life
the singularly best experience of my
life the first day in africa where we
had um
three 280 kids in a room and every
single one of those kids had lost a
parent
every single one of those children they
were aged three
to 17 in that room and my team that
you're talking about i have the greatest
team in the world my team in the here in
the united states had been in contact
with the orphanages so that by the time
we got there
we had a present with every child's name
on it
i had
um uh
this summer
every black doll manufacturer in the
country had sent me dolls because i
these girls had never seen black dolls
and so it was my mission to do for them
what the nuns had done for me was to let
the african girl see a black doll so i
wanted every girl to have a black doll i
wanted every boy to have soccer balls we
bought radios we bought clothes and the
most important thing is we had their
names on every box for every child and i
called up the children one by one and
when those children you know received
their gifts and then waited for the next
child to receive their gifts and said
i said nobody can open their presents
until everybody can open their presents
and on the count of three when i counted
the three and those children opened
their presents was the single greatest
moment of my life
and i share that with you
i share that with you
because that's what i can do i can be i
have a big life so i can take 50 000
presents and do that over and over and
over again to orphanage effort orphanage
but what i felt in that room for those
from those kids
is a lot of what you're talking about
and what you're talking about and what
you see in the faces of those women when
you look into the eyes of someone
and you give them a gift whether that be
a physical gift or it'd be a gift from
your
spiritual self from your presence from
the essence of you and you see the light
you see the joy what i felt in that room
was not just that i was remembered that
that the child felt that i was
remembered but you felt a sense of hope
a sense of validation a sense of
validation that somebody cared about me
and i will tell you that
of all the years and shows that i have
done
and every theme for every show that i've
done
the single common denominator
denominator that i found that every
human being is looking for is validation
every single person needs to know
wants to feel that they matter
that they matter and what happened in
that room that was the greatest day of
my life i knew that those children knew
in that moment that they mattered that
they mattered and so i encourage you
it's exciting to be able to write a
check
it's even more exciting to be able to
touch one life
to be able to do that for one person
it's like cynthia was saying when you
can do that for one person when you can
do that
you will know that your life has meaning
and i will tell you when i left that
place my friend gail and i were there
and we're all boohoo and we're like
booming with the children oh my gosh and
gail was saying what is it what is it
we're so full as gail said to me she
said you know as big as your show is as
big as your show is what happened in
that room seemed bigger
what happened in that room sing bigger
and that is true that is true for me who
has this big life in a television show
and i'm telling you for everybody here
extending yourself beyond your world
your kids your family your stuff and
reaching out to somebody who is not like
you somebody who is like you who is
indeed if you are feeling depressed or
you are feeling down or you're feeling
like things aren't going the way you
want them to go in your life the way you
turn that around is to reach outside of
yourself to somebody else i don't make
resolutions anymore i have a word so at
my dinner table we all go around the
table and we say what's your word for
this year okay and my word is purpose
my word for this year is purpose because
when i look back on my you know how you
can't even figure out what you did in a
year because your life's so full yeah so
another now i just go back and i look
through my phone so i was doing that on
new year's eve looking through the phone
at all the pictures all the stuff you've
done and i did a lot of things but i
didn't do a lot of things on purpose
with intentional purpose so my thing
this year is don't do anything unless
you have an intention and a purpose
behind it you wish yourself they call
her auntie gayle and me mamo i said you
all wish to have a friend like auntie
gayle
you want to have a friend
who wants
the most the best and the highest for
you i have never seen a person like
gayle i've
never yeah you know everybody especially
if you uh are on the rise in your career
and you have had certain friends and
they all act like they're happy for you
but not everybody's happy for you and
every now and then you can hear just a
teen nazi bit of jealousy you can hear
it you can sense it i've never had a
moment's jealousy from gail in you know
the 30 odd years of her friendship
except for the one time
i was on stage dancing with tina turner
in all of the years of doing the oprah
show
there were many days that i sat in my
chair across from one or two or five or
six or seven people and i would be
so
frustrated
because
i just wanted to shake people sometimes
and say
why
didn't you pay attention
to your life
i said on the show probably the
producers tell me that they counted 33
times but i know i thought it at least a
thousand times i would say
listening to your life
as it whispers to you first so that it
does not have to knock you upside the
head with a brick or come crashing down
on you as a brick wall
is one of the greatest principles of
life because
there are many things that happen in
life that are beyond our control natural
disasters death
unexplained events but there are also
many many many things in life which we
can control and become out of control
because you're just not paying attention
you are sleepwalking through your life
and i have seen this so many times on
the show i wanted to take the guests and
go would you just pay attention so this
is what i've learned and how i've
explained it to myself
life whispers to you all the time
your life is speaking to you
all around from the time you wake up in
the morning
and every single experience that's
coming into
your
personal space
into your physical space all of those
experiences are speaking to you they're
telling you something about your life
and about your circumstances it whispers
and if you don't get the whisper the
whisper gets louder if you don't get the
whisper when it gets louder it gets i
call it like a little pebble like a
little thump upside your head when i was
a kid if i was doing something my
grandmother didn't like she just turned
around and thumped me she wouldn't even
look at me she'd just give me a thump
and i know that's that's my cue to stop
it or you we're gonna get worse
the whisper is the message the pebble or
the thump upside the head usually it's
gone into a problem you don't pay
attention to the problem the problem
becomes a brick upside your head the
brick upside your head is a crisis you
don't pay attention to the brick upside
your head the crisis turns into a
disaster and the whole house brick wall
comes falling down the angel network
i've been on the air for
a long time
but it was the angel network that
actually focused my internal gps it
helped me to decide that i wasn't just
gonna be on tv every day but that the
goal of my shows my interviews my
business my philanthropy all of it
whatever ventures i might pursue would
be to make clear
that
what
unites us
is ultimately
far more redeeming and compelling than
anything that separates me because what
had become clear to me and i want you to
know it isn't always clear in the
beginning because as i said i've been on
television since i was 19 years old
but around 94 i got really clear so
don't expect the clarity to come all at
once to know your purpose right away
but what became clear to me was that i
was here
on earth to use television and not be
used by it
to use television to illuminate the
transcendent power
of our better angels
so
this angel network it didn't just change
the lives of those who were helped but
the lives of those who also did the
helping it reminded us that no matter
who we are
or what we look like or what we may
believe it is both possible
and more importantly it becomes powerful
to come together in common purpose and
common effort what i deeply believe is
not that do unto others as you would
have them do unto you
what you do is already done
that moment in the color purple where
she says everything you ever tried to do
to me
where whoopi says that i see
everything you ever everything you even
try to do to me already done to you so
the law the third law of motion in
physics says that what you're putting
out is coming back
all the time i'm going to continue
developing shows that speak uh
to
the humanity of people in a way that
makes them want to
live better and do better
and
that exalts their
their their victories and lets them know
that they are important and meaningful
in the world you know i would have to
say
that
every day david that show was such a it
was like therapy for me kind of like now
uh
every day this show
was
i paid attention so i've never been to a
therapist but uh i i i paid attention
all those days on the show and i made
therapy acceptable for a lot of people
who thought uh not me not so
one of the things i started to get
uh
around
mid to late no no mid to late 90s is
that everybody that i had on the show at
the end of the show would say something
to me like
um
was that okay was that okay how was that
was that okay
at the end of the interview
and i started to then track it it didn't
matter if it was um i i i had gone and
done a show where i was in um a prison i
was interviewing a father
who
was in jail for life for murdering his
twin daughters and at the end of the
interview even behind bars he said to me
is that okay
how'd i do
and barack obama said it when he sat in
the chair the first time and
george bush said it beyonce said it at
the end of she taught me how to talk and
then said is that okay
so that's an acquired skill do they yes
working thing but this is what i learned
uh sitting in that chair for 25 years
that at the end of the day
whether you are
interviewing me or i get to interview
you
whatever your profession is
wherever you are in your life in your
relationships
every person that you encounter
every experience the person wants to
know
was that okay
was that okay
and what i started to hear was that what
people are really saying is did you hear
me
did you hear me and did what i say mean
anything to you you will find true
success and happiness
if you have only one goal there really
is only one and that is this
to fulfill
the highest
most truthful
expression of yourself
as a human being
you want to max out your humanity
by using your energy to lift yourself up
your family and the people around you
theologian howard thurman said it best
he said don't ask yourself what the
world needs
ask yourself what makes you come alive
and then go do that because what the
world needs is people who have come
alive
the world needs
[Applause]
[Music]
people like michael stalzenberg from
fort lauderdale when michael was just
eight years old michael nearly died from
a bacterial infection that cost him both
of his hands and both of his feet
and in an instant this vibrant little
boy became a quadruple amputee
and his life
was changed forever
but in losing who he once was
michael discovered who he wanted to be
he refused to sit in that wheelchair all
day and feel sorry for himself so with
prosthetics he learned to walk
and run and play again
he joined his middle school lacrosse
team
and last month when he learned that so
many victims of the boston marathon
bombing would become new amputees
michael decided to banish that darkness
with light
michael and his brother harris created
mikeysrun.com
to raise one million dollars for other
amputees
by the time harris runs the 2014 boston
marathon
more than a thousand miles away from
here
these two young brothers
are bringing people together to support
this boston community the way their
community came together to support
michael and when this 13 year old man
was asked about his fellow amputees he
said this
first
they will be sad
they're losing something
they will never get back
and that's scary
i was scared
but they'll be okay
they just don't know that yet
we might not always know it
we might not always see it or hear it on
the news
or even feel it in our daily lives but i
have faith
that no matter what
class of 2013
you will be okay
and you will make sure our country is
okay
i have faith because of that
nine-year-old girl who went out and
collected the change
i have faith because of david and
francine wheeler i have faith because of
michael and harris stolzenberg and i
have faith because of you the network of
angels sitting here today one of them
khadijah williams who came to harvard
four years ago
khadijah had attended 12 schools in 12
years
living out of garbage bags
amongst pimps and prostitutes and drug
dealers
homeless
going into department stores walmart in
the morning to bathe herself so that she
wouldn't smell in front of her
classmates
and today she graduates as a member of
the harvard class
of 2013. for me colored girl negro child
growing up in mississippi
that one of the greatest gifts i was
ever afforded was not to have been put
in a segregated school system
had i been put in a segregated school
and taught in a segregated school system
that said you're less than because
you're a woman and you're less than
because you're a colored woman
i probably wouldn't be here today i
would have had to then overcome that
belief that conditioning of a belief but
because
i was raised by a grandmother
who
raised me in the church
and
i went to church
sunday school
um
lived in the church
and i would sit there
second pew
on the right
third row
every sunday
just
taking it all in and i would listen to
the stories listen to the bible stories
and i would hear
that through god all things are possible
i would hear the story of jesus talking
about
if you have the faith of a mustard seed
and you know as many years later that i
actually
saw a mustard seed i could not believe
what a mustard seed actually look like
have you ever seen a mustard seed here i
have some here
i want to pull one out now jesus said if
you had the faith of a mustard seed you
could move mountains
and anything was possible now i heard
this as a kid and i really believed it
and so the question is what do you
believe
do you believe that you are worthy of
happiness do you believe that happiness
success
abundance
comfort fulfillment peace
joy
love
is a part of your birthright
is that what you believe
or do you believe something else because
you will
manifest
the life that you believe
i've always known that no matter what my
belief is i'm going to be all right
empowerment is authority
it is a sign permission slip to actually
seize the day
it's the process of getting stronger and
more confident and more engaged and to
be empowered is to move to the world
without any kind of fear or any kind of
apology and with these gifts comes an
even deeper privilege i believe and that
is the ability to take charge of your
own life to own yourself and claim your
rights and here's what i know for sure
that to whom much is given much is
expected
and i have been given so much
i've earned it
i've been blessed with it
but i've been given a lot
and that's why i've chosen to use my
life to lift other people up nobody's
journey is seamless or smooth we all
stumble we all have setbacks if things
go wrong you hit a dead end as you will
it's just life's way of saying
time to change course
so ask every failure this is what i do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time i say what is this here
to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson
you get to move on if you really get the
lesson you pass and you don't have to
repeat the class if you don't get the
lesson it shows up wearing another pair
of pants or skirt
to give you some remedial work
and what i found is that difficulties
come when you don't pay attention to
life's whisper
because life always whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
whisper sooner or later you'll get a
scream
whatever you resist persists but if you
ask the right question not why is this
happening but what is this here to teach
me what is this here to teach me it puts
you in the place and space to get the
lesson you need my friend ed cartoli
who's written this wonderful book
uh called a new earth
that's all about letting the awareness
of who you are stimulate everything that
you do he puts it like this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge with that situation instead and
the solution will arise from the
challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
hennessey said i started this school
in africa
and
i founded the school where i'm trying to
give south african girls a shot at a
future like yours stanford
and i spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students
i wanted every girl to feel her worth
reflected in her surroundings so i
checked every blueprint
i picked every pillow
i was looking at the grout in between
the bricks i knew every thread count of
the sheets i chose every girl from the
villages from nine provinces and yet
last fall i was faced with a crisis i'd
never anticipated i was told that one of
the dorm matrons was suspected of sexual
abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first i cried actually i sobbed for
about a half an hour
and then i said let's get to it
that's all you get is a half an hour you
need to focus on the now what you need
to do now so i contacted a child trauma
specialist i put together a team of
investigators i made sure the girls had
counseling and support and gail and i
got on a plane and flew to south africa
and the whole time i kept asking that
question
what is this here to teach me
and as difficult as that experience has
been
i got a lot of lessons
i understand now the mistakes i made
because i
had been paying attention to all of the
wrong things
i built that school from the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out
so it's a lesson that applies to all of
our lives as a whole what matters most
is what's inside what matters most is
the sense of
integrity of quality and beauty i got
that lesson and what i know is is that
the girls came away with something too
they've emerged from this more resilient
and knowing that their voices
have power i have always known this
about celebrity
the real
power of being
somebody that somebody knows and i
really think that the only difference
between being famous and not is that
more people know your name
so the only difference
between understanding that
is understanding that what selma has
done what susan has done what anna has
done rebecca has done what jim has done
what i've done
you two can do
because true philanthropy comes from
living from the heart of yourself
and giving what you have been given
how will you do that
how will you use
your personality
the energy of your personality to serve
that
which is your soul's calling
i know this for sure
any life
no matter how fantastic it is
how glorious it seems how much attention
you receive how much square footage you
have
any life and every life is enhanced by
the sharing and the giving and the
opening up of the heart space
your life gets better when you can find
a way to share it with someone else
so what we've done you can do the real
empowerment comes when every person
leaves this room
and makes a decision
makes a decision
maybe that decision is that you will
write a check and support some of the
wonderful organizations you've heard
here today
but the true decision is
how will you use yourself
how will you use everything that you
have been given
to serve that which is greater than
yourself
how will you use that to become
truly
authentically empowered
now
it is a beautiful thing to receive an
award and to be on the cover of a
variety thank you very much
it's a beautiful thing
but the true reward is in the lives that
you are able to touch and the people who
you know you have impacted are you ready
to allow abundance and blessings people
can't figure out how i got to be so
successful it is because i have lived in
the space of spirit my whole life my
favorite
bible verse because i am christian uh is
acts
something
i used to note a number but this is an
axe y'all can google it
but it says thank you 17 28.
in god i live
and move and have my being
i live and move and have my being and
you want to know why i am really so
successful i knew that at four years old
i knew that when my grandmother said you
better watch me now because one day you
have to learn how to wash these clothes
and hang them up like this so watch how
i hold these clothes pins in my mouth
[Applause]
and the reason i could do that is
because spirit
otherwise known as intuition
my instinct said
that's not gonna be my life
so we all have that spiritual side and
this lesson tonight is about connecting
to it i believe that beneath the surface
of all physical problems is a spiritual
solution there is a spiritual solution
why because you are a spiritual being
having a human experience that's the
beginning of understanding spirituality
you are a spiritual being
having a human
experience i had a job until i could
figure out what it was really
what that gave my life its purpose and
meaning
and um i'd gotten demoted in my job in
baltimore as an anchor woman because
as they hired me and then they decided i
was the wrong color
and i was the wrong size and i was the
wrong you know i had lots of problems
and they were trying to take me off the
air
and um
i was making 22 000 a year i thought i
was in heaven because i was making my
age and my dream at the time was gail
and i used to say can you imagine if
you're 40 and you're making 40 000 would
that be it so um
uh that was as big as my dream was just
to make my age
and then i did this they they put me on
a talk show one morning because um
they didn't know what to do with me
and and i was interviewing the carvel
ice cream man it was a local talk show
and
um
benny from um
benny who was miss
chancellors
uh butler or something on all my
children anyway my soap opera star who
wasn't the lead star remember benny
benny and the caravel ice cream man
that's how i cut my teeth and i finished
that show so it's not about the the
stars themselves or whoever the guests
were but i felt like this is what i'm
supposed to do all these years have been
misplaced in news because i couldn't
relate to news i was a news reporter and
i'd be out on the stories and i'd be
crying with the people
and i felt that i was exploiting the
people with news i couldn't
you know put a microphone in people's
face when they were going through
tragedies and stuff i just was so
emotional i was always getting little
notes from my boss about cut that out
you need to stop so but the moment i did
that talk show i felt like oh
i can be myself
and that was uh august 14th 1978
and that was the beginning of fulfilling
the calling and so since that time
since that time august 14th 1978 i've
never had a problem with energy now when
i was working in news i used to be
exhausted all the time
i just exhausted all the time because i
hated it
and the reason i didn't quit is because
i'm not a quitter number one and cause
my father was like better not quit that
job you're making twenty two thousand
dollars a year
who's gonna play a black woman twenty
two thousand dollars a year you're never
gonna make make that kind of money again
you better save half of it so
i i was reluctant to quit and think
about doing something else because i
thought okay everybody wants to be an
anchor woman at the time that was like
supposedly a big deal being an anchor
woman so i thought okay i won't i'll
just stay with this until i can figure
out what is the best thing to do
and interestingly enough i was applying
for what i wanted to do
i felt like i needed to be able to talk
and at the time the only thing that was
available was um
was uh like good morning america or
today show so i called up this agent and
i asked if he would accept my tape
because i wanted to be like a substitute
for brian gumbel and he said to me
there was only going to be one brian
gumbel and so
there wasn't going to be another one
that they weren't going to let another
black person on that show he said that
to me
and um
interestingly enough he called me last
week because somebody else mentions it
to say he never said it but he did say
it and i said to him you know what if
you're ever told that you never forget
it if somebody ever says to you if
you're ever rejected in that way you
never ever ever forget it i said but
it's okay i did okay you did okay
it's all right but the answer to your
question is if you can find what is your
passion if you find what you love you
never get tired or if you do get tired
you you're fueled by the energy of your
work so i know that i'm doing exactly
what i'm supposed to be doing at this
time
i also know that what this this show can
do
in terms of being
a voice and changing the world it's just
the beginning of what this show can do
it's fun to do things like this
but uh and it's necessary to do things
like this in order to be able to do the
bigger grander things to change what
happens to to the face of children in
africa for example what happens to
education with kids in in this country
so i believe that um
that what has happened to me is really
the beginning
of the greater passion to come
but if you find out what you're supposed
to do and you know what you're supposed
to do by how it feels
you know people wait on the voice of god
to be some the moses in burning bush i
think that was only bible talk
you know because he doesn't come to
burning bushes for people he comes
through your heart
he speaks through your heart through
your feelings and so you know what if
you're doing the right thing if it feels
like it's right to you and when you hit
the thing that feels right when you know
it's the right thing you would you know
it's right because it gives you your
juice
and you know it's right because you
would do it for nothing
you would do it for nothing and find a
way to be able just to do it
in order to be able to continue
that's how you know you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing how do i
define success
let me tell you money's pretty nice
i'm not going to stand up here and tell
you that it's not about money because
money is very nice
i like money
it's good for buying things
but having a lot of money does not
automatically
make you a successful person
what you want is money
and meaning
you want your work to be meaningful
because meaning is what brings the real
richness to your life
what you really want is to be surrounded
by people you trust
and treasure and by people who cherish
you
that's when you're really rich i'm
content i'm not just relaxed i'm content
because i know a lot of rich people who
are not happy
but i am not one of them
but when you're recruiting i am one of
the happiest rich people you are ever
going to see
when you're trying to just
when you're trying to get away from it
all and just get away from everything
you just relax at one of your homes or
yes i realize well and also it doesn't
take a lot for me to relax i can uh i
can be happy looking at a leaf yeah
gayle is saying what are you sitting out
under the trees with your thoughts and
i'll say yeah i'm really i could be
happy with a book i can be happy reading
poetry i can be happy in front of a fire
i can be happy time to time you may
stumble
fall you will for sure count on this
no doubt
you will have questions
and you will have doubts about your path
but i know this if you're willing to
listen
to be guided by that still small voice
that is the gps within yourself
to find out what makes you come alive
you will be more than okay
you will be
happy
you will be successful
and you will make a difference in the
world you know i managed to get here
stedman and i have
absolutely uh differing philosophies
because he um teaches
um the idea of he has a book called um
not yeah what is a book
called the book is called you can make
it happen nine steps to success and he's
always um talking to me about
having a vision that would with no
vision that people perish and i always
say i didn't have a vision i didn't have
a vision to get here to where i am my
vision was of surrendering to what i
believe was god's vision for me and i
always say god can dream a bigger dream
for you that you can dream for yourself
i now believe that i need a vision i
think steadman is finally right
that uh in order to continue to move
forward that i need to develop a vision
for myself and um
one of my big goals is to use this
television show as a forum
and a catalyst for change in people's
lives that's one of them yes the other
is to move out into the world in a more
um
uh impactful global format
to help women and children across the
globe without education the people
perish without education
nobody will be able to survive
without education women cannot overcome
poverty will not be able to learn to
take care of themselves will not be able
to move forward on the planet so i want
to use my life and this television show
to continue to do that you find that
behind the facade of all of your
opinions and your beliefs that at the
heart of us we all
want the same thing i want the same
thing that you want and i know that
whether you are republican or democrat
or libertarian or whatever you call
yourself that underneath every body is
this desire need to be valued and to
know that what you say what you think
what you want to do in the world your
fullest expression of yourself that that
thing matters i think some people think
that are under the impression that i was
born empowered that i was born
coming out of the womb ready to
interview a klansman
then cut to commercial we'll be right
back
but the truth is
i know very well what it's like to be
marginalized to be told either
subtly or quite directly that my
contribution
isn't or wasn't welcome
that my face was invisible and that my
needs were an affront so back when i was
doing the news in baltimore i asked to
be paid the same as my co-anchor who did
exactly the same job as i was doing
and i
expected that i would be compensated so
i went in and i asked that i would get
the same amount of money so he was doing
the same job i was doing except that he
called me babe all the time babe yeah
babe
anyway i was told by my news director
and by the general manager because first
i went the news director then i was
general manager and i was told that
because i was a single woman
who didn't have a mortgage and i didn't
have kids that i was not entitled to
earn the same kind of money as the man
who was sitting next to me
doing the same thing
and i realized in that moment that my
employers did not get it they did not
understand my value
but you know what i did
so cut to am chicago the team's hard at
work
and they had been working for a long
time
and after a year or so
we were asked to be syndicated that work
began to pay off and before long we were
now no longer called am chicago we're
the national oprah winfrey show i got a
raise this is before i own myself
so
i got a raise
but my producers did not so i went into
the boss at the time and i asked that my
producers who incidentally were all
female
i asked that they would be given a pay
raise increase
and my boss this is in 1986 said why
they're only
girls what do they need more money for
girls
i've used the word affectionately
sometimes referring to women as girls
and
there was no affection in his tone it
was absolutely condescending so
uh
you know it takes a while to develop a
voice
but once you have it you damn sure
better use it on stuff that matters
so i took a deep breath in that moment
and said
either
they're going to get raises
or i'm going to sit down
i'm not going to work if they don't get
paid more
babe
now
[Music]
i would like to believe that i could
have spoken that kind of truth to
misogyny even if i'd been all by myself
but here i was on the brink of finally
getting what i really wanted and had
been working uh many years for a
national show
i mean i might have been too intimidated
to stand my own ground against this guy
if i were actually alone but here's the
thing you're never
alone you're never alone
the sovereign sound of maya angelou's
voice
was pushing me forward that day
whispering
i come as one
but i stand as ten thousand
so when i was faced with the opportunity
to advocate for my producers
i silently called on some of the ten
thousand
and walked into my boss's office
hand in spirit
with the women who had come before me
i could feel bessie smith
and billy holliday and ella fitzgerald
and pearl bailey and sarah vaughan and
lena horne clutching their green books
looking for a place to eat while they
sang in supper clubs for whites only
and i could feel
reese taylor and rosa parks refusing to
relinquish their dignity in the face of
death threats all these women were with
me that day walking into the office in
chicago as was diana carroll and petula
clark and joan baez and mary tyler moore
and mom's maybelli and barbara walters
and all of the astonishing women whose
names none of us will ever even know
despite their sacrifice and i'm pretty
sure
i even heard shirley chisholm
urging me on with this thought
if they don't give you a seat at the
table
bring a folding chair
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and i understood
i understood that there were so many
times that many women from my mother's
generation and god knows my
grandmother's generation who were forced
to grit their teeth and just take it
because standing up for themselves
wasn't even an option
the risk was too great and they knew it
but they also knew in their bones what
my dear friend maya puts so eloquently
into words when she says you may not
control all the events that happen to
you
but you can decide not to be reduced by
them
because these women and so many others
like them made the decision not to allow
themselves to be reduced by the many
injustices they were subjected to
i found the strength to act if not just
for myself
not just for my producers but for all
the women who in their ingenious ways
subverted the rules
laid the foundation and pushed the
envelope just a little bit further for
me i know exactly the moment i started
to feel valued and for me it was school
i wanted to be a fourth grade teacher
because of mrs duncan and i haven't seen
mrs duncan since then and mrs duncan is
here today
the moment i felt the most value
was
in my fourth grade class when mrs duncan
said to me
i i was the one who was chosen to lead
the class and whatever it was so what
was i like i don't i don't really
remember it's i do remember you that was
remember you were such a fluent reader
well if i had had a class full of
students like oprah i would have been
floating on air
mrs duncan instilled in me this
sense of
believing that i mattered
and that is what every human being is
looking for when you first heard that i
had like done something in life where
did you know that it was me
yes i kept it with you without your
being aware of it and it was mrs duncan
who helped heal you for me yes it was
mrs duncan and then it was my my sixth
grade teacher mr graham it was school
that made me feel a sense of value and
connection
you learned a lot on this story oh i
learned a lot in the story the story was
life-changing for me life-changing
really life-changing people use that
word rhetorically
life changing it's changed the way i
operate with
in my business with my people with my
school
one two three
you say that the most important question
to ask
of people who have gone through trauma
is not what's wrong with you
but what happened to you yeah yeah yeah
so when you see
you know a church being shot up or you
see you know all of the
headline making uh stories of people
seemingly gone mad your first thought is
what happened to that person right right
you know what has been life-changing for
me um is the question
what happened to you
not what is wrong with you but what
happened to you which is an important
question not just for people who have
been so-called traumatized but it's the
most important question you can ask of
anyone i can say
that of all the stories i've ever done
in my life and all of the experiences
i've ever had and people i've
interviewed this story has had more
impact on me than
practically anything i've ever done
it's changed the way you see everyone
it's changed the way i see
everyone
so when i have an employee who is acting
out of line or who is just being a jerk
i don't think what's wrong with that guy
what's wrong with that girl what's wrong
with that bro i think i wonder what
happened to them
i wonder what happened to them i wonder
what happened that caused them to behave
that way that's what this story did for
me for me i've already made more money
than i expected i've already got more
shoes than i know
and i'm like okay what to do with the
shoes
you know so and it never was about
material possessions i don't think if i
could have um
if i'd sat down
and said how do i dream myself up to be
able to get all this i wouldn't have
known how to do it so i was driven by a
passion that was bigger than the show in
the beginning and i believe that in
order to continue every person has a
responsibility to use their life
you
everybody who came here today your life
may not be as big as mine meaning not as
many people know you and the only
difference between being famous and not
is that more people know your name the
real reality is what uh billy was
singing and what um maddie talks about
in his poetry is that we are really all
alike
except for our hair we are really
we are really all alike and that has
been one of the greatest lessons i've
learned in doing this television show is
that what everybody is looking for
is validation yeah in every experience
people are looking to know that they
matter that you matter that i matter in
every encounter and all your fights at
home
all your arguments with your boss or
with your children with your husband
when you really peel back the layers and
get down to what is what is this what
are we arguing about you're arguing you
want to say i matter and i think that um
um
what we've been able to do on this show
is to help people see that for
themselves and if i can be able to give
that back to people in a way that makes
them matter to themselves then this is
worth
billions of dollars
it's priceless it's priceless to be able
to do that
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there